sie alle reden derzeit über das corona
virus kommt nun doch über einen
schlüsselfaktor ohne den es zu dieser
epidemie womöglich gar nicht gekommen
wäre spricht niemand es geht um die
funktionsweise des chinesischen
gesundheitssystems und inwieweit dieser
erst den ausbruch der seuche ermöglicht
gut lasst euch entführen in die skurrile
gefährliche welt des chinesischen
turbokapitalismus hokuspokus
krebstherapie mit getrockneten gekko
eidechsen und nationalistischer
propaganda all das in einer bunten und
hochexplosiven mischung am ende dieses
videos werdet ihr über ein weiteres
wichtiges puzzlestück zum verständnis
der krise bescheid wissen lasst uns also
anfangen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
okay hier kommt sie jene frage die uns
unsere enkel stellen werden wo wann hast
du weißt es gerade in corona virus
passierte und ich bin mir sicher wir
alle werden uns an bilder wie diese
erinnern
jena sichert sich führungspositionen im
kampf gegen das corona virus und schick
erste und maske nach übersee während die
zahl der heimischen infektionen sinkt ja
wir alle haben diese nachrichten gesehen
über jenes china das medizinische
experten und hilfsmittel für europäische
länder schickt auf einmal sind für die
ganze welt abermillionen von
atemschutzmasken viren testkits und
krone ersten scheinbar
überlebensnotwendig geworden einige
medien loben china bereits dafür in den
himmel und auch dafür dass ist all das
tat was getan werden musste um die
infektion einzudämmen
[Musik]
und doch um dies wirklich beurteilen zu
können ist da noch etwas was wir
unbedingt verstehen müssen die
funktioniert das chinesische
gesundheitssystem und könnte das corona
virus nicht doch irgendwann zu einem
chinesischen bio tschernobyl werden nun
die gesundheitsvorschriften in china
bewegen sich im vergleich zu europa war
sehr sehr niedrigen niveau und falls ihr
mal in china was habt ihr sie vielleicht
auch gesehen die so genannten web mache
es also wörtlich nachts märkte auf denen
ohne handschuhe mit lebensmitteln
montiert wird und hygienekontrollen so
gut wie gar nicht statt denn sicherlich
keine guten voraussetzungen um sich vor
gefährlichen keimen zu schützen nicht
wahr davon ausgehen haben wir damit
begonnen den gesamten system der
gesundheitsversorgung in china auf den
zahn zu fühlen
werden zum beispiel die krankenhäuser
privat betrieben werden sie staatlich
gefördert wie funktioniert das ganze
überhaupt liebe leute was wir
herausgefunden haben wird euch umhauen
[Musik]
die frage lautet nun also das
gesundheitssystem seinen schlechten ruf
zu recht warum lehnen es so viele
chinesen ab zum arzt zu gehen und das
wichtigste von allem trifft die
chinesische kommunistische partei in der
verantwortung dafür dass sich die solche
ausbreiten konnte heute werden wir alle
diese fragen beantworten aber da wir
über ein gesundheitsthema sprechen haben
wir auch einen arzt als berater
hinzugezogen
es handelt sich dabei um keinen
geringeren als doktor amiando an der auf
youtube einen wunderbaren
spanischsprachigen kanal über gesundheit
mit dem namen global ursula vielleicht
kennt ihr ihn nicht aber in spanien ist
am iat eine echte größe und wie immer
werden wir außerdem zunächst einen blick
zurück in die geschichte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
barfuß in den kapitalismus im jahr 1949
gelangte marathon in china an die macht
erst wird eine riesiges land vor dass
wie in alten zeiten eingefroren schien
in den meisten chinesischen dörfern
hatte man von moderner medizin noch rein
gar nichts gehört und china damals
einfach nicht genug geld hatte um genug
ärzte auszubilden das riesenland braucht
nämlich viele viele erste fand meine
kreative lösungen die so genannten
barfuß erste
hier erfolgt der barfuß erste lag darin
dass die 90 chinesischen bevölkerung
versorgen konnten medizinisches wissen
erfüllte nur minimal anforderungen aber
es umfasse drei grundlegende leistungen
die betreuung bei der geburt was zu
einer verringerung der
kindersterblichkeit führte die
durchführung von breit angelegten
impfungen was für die verhütung von
infektionskrankheiten und alles nicht
wahr und die aufklärung über
grundlegende hygiene was einen großen
beitrag zur verhinderung möglicher
epidemien leistete und ja ich weiß was
ich jetzt unbedingt wissen wollt mag
sind diese barfuß erste wirklich alle
ohne schwung herumgelaufen nun nein sie
hatten schuhe aber denkt gerade dass sie
auf dem land tätig waren und wenn sie in
der eisfelder gehen mussten um jemanden
zu behandeln hatten sie keine andere
wahl als dort barfuß hinzugehen
zumindest wenn sie wollten dass ihre
schuhe bis zum nächsten fünf jahres bann
halten in den 80er und 90er jahren wurde
jedoch deutlich dass das konzept der
basis erst nicht mehr zeitgemäß war das
land wuchs schnell und der wohlstand der
menschen stieg beständig alles schien
gut zu laufen bis auf zwei dinge
umweltschutz und gesundheitsfürsorge
[Musik]
die kosten des chinesischen
gesundheitswesens zwingen die patienten
in die schuldenfalle denkt darüber nach
das moderne marktwirtschaftlich
orientierte china wollte moderne
krankenhäuser die barfuß erste mündete
nun wie ein anachronismus an und der
schnellste weg all die neuen modernen
krankenhäuser zu bauen war ein
vollständig privat wirtschaftliches
system das gesundheitssystem wurde also
privatisiert
[Musik]
die neue wirtschaftspolitik chinas
verlangte von den menschen vor allem
eines geld zu verdienen viel geld genug
um ihre erst rechnen bezahlen zu können
mit anderen worten china wollte weg von
einem system in dem alle gleich arm sind
hin zur devise haye wäre es nicht besser
wenn alle reich wären das enorme
wirtschaftswachstum chinas in diesen
jahres hinten ist jedem bekannt um das
problem das dabei entstand ist das
übliche die ungleichheit so hatten im
jahr 2000 nur 30 prozent der
chinesischen bevölkerung eine
krankenversicherung alle anderen müssten
mit bargeld zum arzt und bei einem
arztbesuch konnte schon mal ein ganzes
monatsgehalt rausgehen außerdem wurde
auf die gesundheits versorgung
ländlicher gebiete kein besonders großer
wert gelegt deshalb zogen die chinesen
ist vor in krankenhäuser in der stadt zu
gehen ein durchschnittlicher einwöchige
takten haus aufenthalt konnte den
gegenwert von drei monatsgehältern
kosten zudem ist china das einzige land
in ostasien in denen die impfung von
kindern kostenpflichtig ist und
angesichts dieser turbokapitalistischen
zustände sind krankheiten die china
einst unter kontrolle hatte wieder
zurückgekehrt so zum beispiel
tuberkulose masern uns sogar wurm
erkrankt
[Musik]
aber das allerschlimmste für die
chinesin ist dass diese
gesundheitsversorgung sie ein vermögen
kostet und obendrein müssen sie dem arzt
auch noch ein saftiges trinkgeld geben
wenn sie auch noch gut behandelt werden
wollen chinesische arzt nahm berichten
zufolge bestechungsgelder im wert von
mehr als 18 millionen dollar an doch in
den letzten zehn jahren haben sich die
dinge geändert was genau dass er in der
os x an dem avaya wie agra während der
sars krise im jahr 2003 verfügte die
chinesische regierung dass die
betroffenen kostenlos behandelt werden
sollten doch dies brachte die menschen
in eine zwickmühle denn viele chinesen
bezahlst gehen gar nicht zum arzt da sie
angst hatten dass dieser bei ihnen nur
eine normale grippe diagnostiziert denn
dann müssten sie die saftige arzt
rechnungen selbst bezahlen und wenn die
menschen große angst haben zum arzt zu
gehen ist das für jedes land ein
gravierendes problem die im jahr 2009
begonnenen reformen des
gesundheitssystems haben nach und nach
veränderungen besetzt
die wichtigste davon ist das jetzt 95
der bevölkerung über eine
krankenversicherung verfügen aber wartet
einen moment denn auch das hat noch
nicht alle probleme gelöst die
versicherung deckt nur zwischen 50 und
75 prozent der kosten ab wenn die
krankheit also schwer ist und die
behandlungskosten ausufern müssen die
chinesen tief in die tasche greifen und
das kann sich nun mal nicht jeder
leistung tatsächlich vereint das
chinesische gesundheitssystem das
schlimmste beider welten die schlimmsten
eigenschaften eines vollständig privaten
gesundheitssystems kombiniert mit den
schlimmsten stehlen einer allgemeinen
krankenversicherung die regierung will
also einerseits den bürgern helfen die
kosten für ihre gesundheitsversorgung zu
decken
andererseits muss sie aber auch die
staatsausgaben im auge behalten was tut
sie also ohne sie liegt höchstbeträge
für die kosten der behandlung von
kassenpatienten fest die krankenhäuser
vom staat beanspruchen können
[Musik]
etwa 1700 dollar pro patient in den
besten städtischen krankenhäusern in
ländlichen gebieten deutlich weniger
folglich werden nur sehr wenige
patienten länger als zwei wochen im
krankenhaus verbringen unabhängig davon
ob sie gesund sind oder nicht und wie
auch immer man es betrachtet das system
scheint recht ineffizient zu sein
einerseits werden die privaten und somit
gewinnorientierten krankenhäuser dadurch
nämlich motiviert die behandlung der
leichten fälle in die länge zu ziehen um
den maximalen zuschuss vom staat zu
erhalten andererseits besteht aber wenig
interesse daran schwer kranke patienten
zu betreuen
die nur über geringe mittel verfügen um
die über den höchst zuschuss
hinausgehende beträge zu bezahlen
hinzu kommt dass sich die kosten für die
gesundheitsversorgung für den staat
vervielfacht haben in welchem ausmaß nun
etwa 300 milliarden dollar pro jahr und
das mal ins verhältnis zu setzen
dieser betrag ist mehr als das ganze
bruttoinlandsprodukt finnlands oder fast
der gesamte staatshaushalt der
niederlande nun wie ihr seht ist das
chinesische gesundheitssystem ein
ziemlicher saustall eine schlechte
gesundheitsversorgung bei exorbitant
ausufernden kosten also trafen sich
eines tages die funktionäre der
kommunistischen partei und haben sich
etwas einfallen lassen und was glaubt
ihr was ihre große lösung war
macht euch bereit der nun kommt die
traditionelle chinesische berichten
[Musik]
und nein bei traditioneller chinesischer
medizin handelt es sich nicht nur um
eine touristenattraktion viele chinesen
glauben weiterhin an diese alten
traditionen die von generation zu
generation weitergegeben wurden und in
einem land das bis vor einigen
jahrzehnten noch keine modernen medizin
hatte verlassen sich die meisten
menschen noch immer auf kräuter
akupunktur und gymnastik im jahr 2016
führte die chinesische regierung eine
regulierung der traditionellen
chinesischen medizin ein und weil sie
erste brauchte doch hatte sie dabei alle
möglichen anforderungen an den arzt
früher brauchte man einen abschluss in
schulmedizin und konnte sich dann wenn
man wollte auch auf esoterische länge
spezialisieren jetzt braucht man nur
noch kenntnisse in der traditionellen
medizin und zwei kollegen die einen eine
empfehlung ausstellen ja genau das hat
ja richtig gehört aber wartet einen
moment ist wird noch besser damit zum
zeitpunkt als wir dieses video trainer
gibt es bereits mehr als 4000
krankenhäuser nur für traditionelle
medizin in china glaubt ihr ich
übertreibe
glaubt ihr das wäre ein witz oder eine
verschwörungstheorie nun die chinesische
regierung macht alles andere als ein
großes geheimnis daraus tatsächlich ist
die chinesische medizin tcm genannt
etwas auf was man doch stolz ist sehen
wir
china hat jetzt 4238 krankenhäuser für
traditionelle chinesische medizin mit
insgesamt 877 1000 betten diese
nachricht stammt nicht von einem china
feindlichen pro westlichen
imperialistischen propaganda outlet
sondern vorne 10 uhr den offiziellen
nachrichten sprachrohr der
kommunistischen partei chinas
mit anderen worten china prallt damit in
welche gewaltigen ausmaß die die
traditionelle chinesische medizin
anwenden und diese ist natürlich
besonders in ländlichen gebieten sehr
beliebt so werden zb viele
krebspatienten mit getrockneten betty
jackson behandelt wenn ein chinese an
erektiler dysfunktion leidet kriegt er
so genannte himalaya viagra verschrieben
das ist ein pilz der entleiher wächst
und da die nachfrage danach in letzter
zeit stark gestiegen ist kostet ein kilo
dieser wunderbaren und natürlichen
medizin mittlerweile mehr als 110.000
dollar
und ich weiß was einige von euch jetzt
denken auch in westlichen ländern wird
ernsthaft über die traditionelle
chinesische medizin diskutiert
aber bisher gibt es keine eindeutigen
und wissenschaftlich fundierten beweise
dafür dass sie überhaupt über den
placebo-effekt hinaus funktioniert daher
raten sowohl der britische ex es als
auch das amerikanische
gesundheitsministerium von solchen
behandlungen ab zwar hat die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu einige
dieser traditionellen praktiken zu
reinen diagnose zwecken aufgenommen
allerdings sollten wir bedenken dass die
whu ein beliebtes ziel von lobbyisten
ist wobei china dort als eines der
mächtigsten bhu mitglieder seit
jahrzehnten massivste lobby arbeit zur
förderung der tcm betreibt und
vielleicht denken einige von euch auch
dass er sich ja um natürliche heilmittel
handelt und das was aus der natur kommt
doch nicht schlecht sein kann oder nun
der dies glaubt sollte nochmal genau
darüber nachdenken wie es der natur in
china so geht
[Musik]
ein fünftel des chinesischen boden ist
verseucht
um euch ein beispiel zu geben im jahr
2013 stellte man fest dass große mengen
reis der in china angebaut wird
unglaublich hohe mengen an
krebserregenden cadmium enthielt und das
war nur ein umweltskandal von unzähligen
in china wenn also der reis
krebserregend ist sind es wahrscheinlich
auch die heilkräuter dann überlegt mal
wenn man ein neues medikament auf den
markt bringen müssen viele labor und
klinische tests durchlaufen werden tja
aber das himalaya viagra kann direkt vom
feld verkauft werden ohne jegliche
kontrollen und jetzt fragt ihr euch
vielleicht was hat das christ nun mit
dem corona virus zu tun nun macht euch
auf etwas gefasst
die rückkehr der fledermäuse ich weiß
dass viele von euch denken und wo ist
das problem bei der traditionellen
medizin wenn jemand nicht daran glaubt
muss er sie jedoch nicht bloß ja das
stimmt aber leider wenden sich in china
viel zu viele menschen von der modernen
medizin und werfen sich in die arme von
scharlatan und dann passieren genau
solche dinge ein chinesisches imperium
für alternative medizin steht unter
beschuss nachdem er zu sagen es habe
einen 4 jährigen kriegs basierten mit
judith he behandelt aber die
traditionelle medizin ist nicht nur für
den menschen sehr gefährlich sondern
auch für die umwelt
das habt ihr richtig gehört sie ist
gefährlich für die umwelt aus
irgendeinem grund erfordern viele
traditionelle behandlungen seltene und
gefährdete tiere tiere von denen es nur
noch wenige exemplare gibt und dann sind
sie plötzlich extrem gefragt so zum
beispiel nashörner schuppentiere und
fledermäuse tja und jetzt könnt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich schon denken hier kommt
das corona virus ins spiel
klassifikation von beta coronaviren und
identifikation der traditionellen
chinesischen medizin als potenzieller
ursprung sunnitischer corona beer
[Musik]
natürlich handelt es sich nur um eine
hypothese in einer studie aber schaut
dies ist nicht das erste mal dass wir
eine corona virus epidemie haben die
sars-epidemie wurde auch durch einen
corona virus verursacht und der
ursprüngliche wird den dieses virus an
den menschen weitergegeben hat war eine
fledermaus der zweite ausbruch des
corona virus war die merz spd die im
jahr 2012 in saudi arabien ausbrach in
diesem fall war das tier von welchen das
virus auf den menschen übertragen wurde
ein kamel aber das kamel wurde durch
eine fledermaus angesteckt mit anderen
worten es sieht danach aus dass einige
fledermausarten ein natürlicher wird von
corona viren sind und es stellt sich
heraus dass ausgerechnet diese art von
fledermäusen in der traditionellen
chinesischen medizin verwendung finden
die ursache der korona virus krise ist
noch nicht bekannt einige theorien
weisenau fledermäuse hin andere auf
schuppentiere wir hier bei visual
politik können diese frage nicht
beantworten aber was wir wissen ist dass
ist einen einflussreichen menschen gibt
der die chinesen dazu ermutigt sehr
seltsame dinge zu essen weil er glaubt
sie würden alle möglichen krankheiten
heilen es handelt sich um diesen feinen
herren sie drängten verstärkten
bemühungen zur förderung der
traditionellen chinesischen medizin und
aus welchem grund wird dcm vorne ganz
oben derartige pusht nun es geht um geld
weil die traditionelle chinesische
medizin pflege ist ist die viel
beliebter nach offiziellen chinesischen
angaben hat die traditionelle medizin
die krankenhauskosten um 24 prozent und
die ambulanten kosten um zwölf prozent
gesenkt sie in pinks narrativ zufolge
ist das was wir wissensbasierte oder
schulmedizin denn nur westliche medizin
er behauptet die traditionelle medizin
sei nur eine andere art von medizin
genauso gut und schlecht wie die
wissenschaftsbasierte oder vielleicht
sogar besser
aber auf jeden fall ist sie auf
chinesisch 4000 jahre alt und seit dies
nicht der perfekte beweis dafür dass der
sozialismus chinesischer prägung besser
ist als die ganzen verlotterten
westlichen demokratien die tcm ist also
das perfekte nationalistische propaganda
mittel für die chinesische kp all dies
erklärt die großen anstrengungen chinas
dtcm überall zu kooperieren bei der bh
und auch in den westlichen medien ja ihr
habt mich richtig verstanden ich spreche
nicht von fake news websites ganz und
gar nicht hört euch folgendes sagen
[Musik]
rona virus kann die traditionelle
chinesische medizin helfen die krankheit
zu bekämpfen diese nachricht stammt von
der deutschen welle einem sender der ard
ich meine wir sprechen hier von einer
maßgeblichen quelle mit unbestrittener
reputation und von offiziellen
chinesischen medien erfahren sie
natürlich auch solche dinge
traditionelle chinesische medizin wirkt
laut regierungsbeamten gegen neues
corona virus die kernfrage lautet nun
also ist die esoterische behandlung mit
leder neuson der grund für die
übertragung des corona virus auf den
menschen und den ausbruch der korona
solche mit hundertprozentiger gewissheit
wissen wir das noch nicht vielleicht zum
wird man den wahren ursprung dieser
solche nie mehr in erfahrung bringen wie
ihr könnt euch aber eines garantieren
wenn china dies herausgefunden hätte
würden sie es so geheim halten wie trump
und putin ihre atomwaffen kurz zusammen
genommen warum nun ein solcher
gesundheitswelt skandal hätte einfach
das zeug dazu das ganze propaganda
gebilde der cup zum einsturz zu bringen
das bedeutet dass selbst wenn die
aktuelle prognose epidemie irgendwann
besiegt sein wird ihre eigentliche
ursache nach wie vor weiter besteht und
somit ein erhebliches risiko dass
jederzeit wieder neue gefährliche
epidemie auf dieselbe weise ausbrechen
können nur wenn sich die welt endlich
darauf besinnt die hier genannten
ursache zu bekämpfen anstatt ihrer
symptome können wir uns wieder in
relativer sicherheit wiegen tatsache ist
aber dass sich mit den wahren ursachen
so gut wie niemand in der öffentlichkeit
befasst im gegenteil es scheint so dass
hier hier viel unternimmt um sie zu
vertuschen und unter tonnen von
propaganda und fake news zu begraben
denn china ist zum frontalangriff
übergegangen und verbreitet nun sogar
die behauptung das virus sei inhuman
durch das us-militär ausgesetzt worden
das regime spinnt hier also ein
brandgefährliches narrativ mit dem es
die welt an der nase herumführen will
anstatt sich an die eigene zu fassen
und vielleicht war deswegen auch
folgende meldungen kein besonders großer
zufall
chinesische arzt der vor ausbruch einer
seuche gewarnt hatte zum schweigen
gebracht stirbt an corona virus nur so
kann sich jeder seine eigene meinung
bilden aber es ist schwer vorstellbar
dass china in dieser hinsicht
transparent ist denn die regierung
chinas nutzt diese krise wie es nur geht
für ihre eigenen zwecke aus da sind
mitnahmeeffekte in sachen
parteipropaganda das mindeste aber
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich ist dies nur die spitze
des eisbergs in einem anderen video
haben wir euch ja bereits darüber
aufgeklärt wie china die korona krise
missbraucht um sich die hongkonger
fluggesellschaft cathay pacific unter
den nagel zu reißen falls ihr euch
dieses video ansehen wollt klickt auf
den link der jetzt oben erscheint oder
unten in der beschreibung man kann aber
davon ausgehen dass dies nur eines von
vielen beispielen dafür ist wie
geschickt china die krise so michael
macht genutzt so kursieren gerüchte
peking hatte nach ausbruch der epidemie
in china die flucht der internationalen
investoren aus dem land schnell genutzt
und deren aktien spottbillig aufzukaufen
und dann von den gewinnen nach der
erholung kräftig profitieren
[Musik]
ebenso wird nur durch fürchtet dass sich
bereits erholt sich china würde nach dem
abschluss der wirtschaft alle anderen
länder dort sie haben zu spottpreisen
aufkaufen bayerns ministerpräsident
seehofer versprach für diesen fall
bereits bayerische unternehmen vor
solchen übernahmeversuchen mit
staatsgeld zu schützen ist die korona
krise nun also die perfekte gelegenheit
für china sich aus der position des
verlierer ist ein handelskrieg gegen die
usa zu befreien nun denkt mal darüber
nach die letzten zwei jahre waren ein
albtraum so das regime zuerst die
proteste in hongkong dann der
handelskrieg mit den usa und jetzt das
corona virus diese epidemie hatte das
zeug zu einem chinesischen tschernobyl
zu werden genau wie in tschernobyl
brauchte es aber keine gezielte
verschwörung wie man wollte dass der
reaktor explodiert es waren fehlende
sicherheitsmaßnahmen und eine kultur der
intransparenz die zur katastrophe
und auch wenn dieser chor ohne ausbruch
von china bisher relativ glimpflich
ausging handelt es sich nicht um den
ersten und mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
auch nicht um den listen denn dazu
braucht es keine verschwörung und keinen
masterplan dann können wir wirklich
sagen dass sich hier in dieser hinsicht
verantwortungsvoll verhält was meint ihr
hat das gefährliche skurril chinesische
gesundheitssystem hierbei eine rolle
gespielt ticken hier noch weitere
biologische zeitbomben vor denen die
welt zittern sollte kann sich china
nachdem es für den ausbruch des corona
virus eigentlich verantwortlich ist nun
mit dem export seiner rahden schutzmaske
kroner testkits und expert muss für den
rest der pandemie gestrauchelten welt
zum großen retter aufschwingen und quasi
als sieger als krisengewinnler
hervorgehen welche auswirkungen wird
dies auf die macht chinas in der welt
ihr in eurem land haben bitte
hinterlasst eure von uns hoch
geschätzten meinungen die immer im
kommentarbereich unter diesem video wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat teilt es
bitte mit euren freunden geht uns ein
like und vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren und auf das glocken zu
klicken bevor wir es mal ab deuce kommen
möchte ich mich aber auch noch bei
amazon obersuhl bedanken welches bei
diesem video als verband beratend zur
seite stand wenn ihr mehr über
gesundheit erfahren wollt und etwas
spanisch versteht schaut euch bitte
seinen kanal macht gut und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]